[Musique]
on parle beaucoup beaucoup de vous si ce
n'est tout le temps comme étant la
nouvelle génération
mais de mon point de vue je crois que
vous êtes la dernière génération
parlons un petit peu tout d'abord votre
taille
les personnes de moins de 25 ans dans le
monde
ces 42 pour cent quarante deux pour cent
de la population mondiale
si je rajoute les moins de 35 ans et 50%
il n'y a jamais eu dans l'histoire de
l'humanité dans l'histoire démographique
une génération aussi grande aussi
massive que la vôtre la deuxième
caractéristique de vote génération c'est
que vous êtes connecté en permanence
alors vous vous demandez pourquoi est-ce
que je vous montre des chewing gum
la corrélation entre la sortie de
l'iphone et l' effondrement
littéralement du marché du chewing gum
montre à quel point nous sommes passés
d'un outil d'une activité à un état de
connexion permanent et un comportement
le chewing gum c'est ce que vous
achetiez quand vous attendiez en caisse
et d'ailleurs nous allons toujours
autant qu est-ce qu avant vous attendiez
vous faisiez l'accueil puis il y avait
les chewing gum et vous achetiez des
chewing gum l'iphone sort en 2007
voilà le marché du jouet damas il s'est
évidemment effondrée parce que vous ne
regardez plus la tête de gondole quand
vous êtes en caisse mais vous êtes sur
votre iphone derrière moi vous avez la
liste des compétences que votre
génération les jeunes avaient en 2015
alors vous voyez c'est des choses assez
froids de ces des choses très
universitaire c'est des choses qu'on
apprend à l'école qu'on peut apprendre
sur les bancs de la sorbonne ou
d'ailleurs la technologie a eu un impact
extrêmement positif sur ce que vous
savez faire
on dit souvent de vous il ya beaucoup de
clichés sur vous que vous êtes moins
empathique trop connectés décorrélé de
la réalité que vous n'êtes plus dans le
réel
pourtant les compétences que vous aurez
de façon générale l'année prochaine sur
votre marché
elles sont beaucoup plus empathique vous
n'êtes plus créatif vous avez des
compétences cognitives plus forte
vous avez une intelligence émotionnelle
plus affûtés un sens critique plus
puissant
et je veux tendre ici le cou à quelques
clichés qui accompagnent votre
génération
on dit par exemple de vous que vous êtes
une génération qu'il lit plus personne
ne me contredira là tu mets toutes les
études montrent que vous êtes la
génération qui va le plus souvent dans
l'histoire de l'humanité à la
bibliothèque ont dites vous que vous
n'avez plus d'amis parce que vous êtes
connecté en permanence sur votre
téléphone et ça a été un un grand sujet
pour pour facebook
à l'époque où j'y travaillais en 2008
vous aviez entre 1 et 1,5 à bille en
2018 vous en avez entre 3 et 4 ce qui
est fou on dit de vous que vous êtes
égocentré la génération des baby boomers
en moyenne aux états unis avec 85 photos
d'eux et de leurs familles imprimé est
accroché au mur de leur maison n'êtes
donc pas plus vaniteux que la grande
révolution
après tout ces petits sujets toutes ces
critiques quand vous adresse souvent et
qui sont parfois agaçante parce que
aucun chiffre ne va dans le sens de ce
qui est dit c'est que le digital a donné
à chacun d'entre vous une voix vous
entendrez après moi je crois un jeune
talent dylan qui n'a pas 20 ans qui
vient de connaître un très grand succès
qui devient le porte parole de sa
génération
vous voyez derrière moi greta solberg en
suède qui porte l'intégralité d'un
combat contre le réchauffement
climatique
aux etats unis emma gonzalez qui à 19
ans à peine mène la lutte pour le
contrôle des armes à feu sont des gens
qui n'ont pas 20 ans sans le digital ça
n'existe pas et c'est pour ça vous ne
l'avez jamais vue dans l'histoire c'est
pour ça que vous seriez bien en peine de
trouver un exemple plus anciens d'un
leader de cet âge là vous avez touché le
vois aller dans votre poche parce que
évidemment ce téléphone c'est bien plus
qu'un téléphone et c'est internet
l'accès à la connaissance l'accès au
monde dans votre poche
je vais être un tout petit peu triviale
mais l'autre caractéristique et c'est la
dernière de votre génération c'est que
vous tenez les cordons de la bourse
les moins de 35 ans dans le monde ces 24
milliards d'euros directs et indirects
tous les ans dans le monde tous les ans
monde 24 trillard c'est une virgule cinq
fois la taille de l'économie américaine
vous êtes donc la population qui a le
plus d'impact économique dans le monde
vous prenez les singles dijk et cette
initiative très proche du des soldes ou
du black friday y de d'ali baba
ces 28 milliards dépensés en une journée
95% par des gens qui ont moins de 40 ans
donc vous êtes la génération
collectivement la plus grande
vous êtes la génération la plus
connectée
vous êtes la génération dont chacun
d'entre vous a une voix et vous êtes la
génération qui pilote et des sites où va
l'argent
on pourrait se dire génération puissante
il n'est dit tout se passera bien pour
vous c'est là que les mauvaises
nouvelles comme ans votre rencontre avec
tous les piliers de la société
elle est compliquée et elle va être de
plus en plus compliqué
l'éducation d'abord j'ai juste une
question à vous poser est ce que vous
êtes bien assis vous qu'est-ce que vous
avez un peu mal au dos ça tape un peu
c'est pas très agréable je vous vois
vous êtes mal assise par la volonté d'un
homme qui est très symbolique de la
façon dont les systèmes fonctionnent
cardinal richelieu homme d'état français
majeurs beaucoup plus complexe que que
ce à quoi on pourrait s'attendre a été
le doyen de la sorbonne et a fait
installer les bancs sur lesquels vous
êtes assis et ces bons sont
inconfortables parce que pour le
cardinal richelieu
il fallait que vous soyez dans
l'inconfort pour écouter c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui en 2019
vous êtes mal assis pendant 1 tedx c'est
un exemple illustratif très
représentatif de la façon dont beaucoup
de systèmes système d'éducation
notamment fonctionne il vient être une
contrainte
là où ils devraient être beaucoup plus
un facilitateur
deuxième sujet que vous rencontrez et
que vous allez rencontrer le travail ja
sont des chiffres du forum économique
mondial 10 millions de personnes qui
atteignent l'âge de travailler chaque
mois en face on crée un à deux millions
d'emplois
alors moi je ne suis pas mathématicien
comme le doyen de la sorbonne qui
expliquait plus tard mais il en manque 8
donc ça va être un enjeu fondamental et
vous pourriez vous dire c'est très très
loin - en france ce sont des problèmes
pour l'afrique ce sont des problèmes
pour les pays émergents les pays qui
rattrapent des années croissance en
occident si vous regardez les chiffres
français en rouge c'est la france
elle est donc à une marche du podium des
moins bons élèves pour le taux d'emploi
des jeunes
il ya plus de 20% ce qui est énorme
la moyenne du nombre de personnes en cdd
dans des contrats précaires sur cette
même cible sur votre génération en
france c'est le double de la moyenne de
l'oscd vous allez donc arriver dans un
monde dans lequel le trayas
fondamentalement puissamment changé et
puis il ya tous les autres sujets qui
font que nous sommes une société
on a évidemment beaucoup entendu parler
de gilet jaune alors les organisateurs
de tedx monde il faut pas parler de
gilet jaune
j'y vais doucement mais il n'ya que 7 %
des jeunes qui ont participé à gilet
jaune
il ya eu un pic de violence en décembre
et après on n'a plus vu de jeunes avec
avec gilet jaune décision politique
majeure pour le continent européen et
l'union européenne
l'immense majorité des jeunes ont voté
contre
la sortie de l'union européenne si je
prends les partis politiques
c'est presque à 100% de personnes qui ne
font pas confiance aux partis politiques
pour les représenter 98%
ça veut dire une chose extrêmement
simple ça veut dire que le monde de
demain dans lequel vous allez vivre dans
lequel nous allons vivre dans lequel
nous vivons déjà n'est pas construit par
et n'est pas construit pour vous alors
après cet exposé pourrait dire hugo est
pessimiste
on est venu chez tedx pour respirer et c
est en fait on nous dit que c'est mal
barré
je vous rassure vous êtes déjà
pessimiste parce que 71% d'entre vous
déclare que vous pensez que vous allez
moins bien vivre que vos parents 71%
donc vous êtes déjà très très très très
pessimiste je ne veux pas faire de
politique mais le premier parti
politique en france pour les jeunes
c'est le front national qui n'est pas
tout à fait un parti optimiste vous êtes
aussi un petit peu parfois passif il ya
un chiffre qui est pour moi le plus
terrifiant de ce que je vous ai donné en
2002 vous étiez 80 % à vouloir avoir des
postes à haute responsabilité formidable
ambition c'est quelque chose qui nous
fait avancer collectivement
l'année dernière vous étiez plus que 48
%
je ne suis pas là pour faire évidemment
le donneur de leçon ou la morale je fais
partie de cette génération
mais si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités nous allons arriver dans
un système beaucoup plus complexe et
beaucoup plus tendue et si votre
génération notre génération est dans
cette situation c'est parce que la
génération qui nous précèdent au sens
large
les baby boomers ont été les chantres de
l'ultralibéralisme qui accouche de
l'individualisme ont profité de
croissances à deux chiffres dans
certains pays ont personnellement se
sont beaucoup plus riches mais n'ont pas
préparé la suite de ces phases de
croissance pour doux et si vous ne
prenez pas et nous prenons pas nos
responsabilités pour préparer la suite
c'était le titre de cette présentation
j'ai bien peur que nous soyons la
dernière génération à connaître le monde
tel qu'il est merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]